this is the new office and my brother
what's going on welcome welcome to
incredible this is your world isn't it
man I live here literally I'm here this
is my business this is my creative space
so we we here man okay so what's in your
creative space I mean give me a little
tour it just it's always yes this box
like everybody who's ever kind of pulled
up I have people sign the wall just kind
of has that that energy of like
youthfulness you know I'm a big kid at
heart yeah so but you know this is my
kind of my area over here this is where
I can do a lot of the podcast uh it's
the conference room we take meetings and
stuff in here this is my this is
literally my office where this is your
office yeah where I got the DJ set up
twitch you know my massage chair my
guitar
uh all my books uh and then of course
right next to me I gotta have the kids
it's the nurse how many kids can you get
in there
uh but yeah man so I think this is where
I'm this area right here I'm constantly
this is I don't move from this during
business hours and then downstairs is
where we do it I gotta I gotta point
something out that I love that was in
here this picture right here
oh that's me and my mom I know
this is almost like all of this stuff
like oh my entire family wherever it is
like all of the kids and just memories
my grandfathers like it's so it's it's
really a Vibe man where I and the stuff
that stuff my kids make me is always
like the sweetest stuff these like
Valentine's Day gifts and stuff
it's real in here you know what I see
the I see the Mariah billboard
I just saw the tick tock
[Music]
how was that did you see her I loved it
to me that was epic in the sense of
where I always even said like my
daughter has the the entertainment bug
has bitter yeah she is definitely see
that connection with her and her mom is
beautiful because the fact that they get
to have fun with each other and not it's
not necessarily like Tick Tock is
amazing I mean I do tick tocks with them
as well every but to be able to connect
like families connecting in a different
way but than ever before is she a singer
yes really but you know like like her
and Mariah they don't they they doing
what they do like that's so wow so I
don't even know if I'm allowed to talk
about it right that's because Mariah's
like let me handle this I got you she
got it but even like they did a
performance on her Christmas show and
she hit the high no whistle note and
everything so
[Music]
I'm proud of you when you see your child
do that man it's crazy and it's funny
too man like to even that that song that
they were uh doing a tick tock tools uh
that's a song that you know I produce
and worked on with Mariah Professor like
even that made it special yeah and that
that Vibe so it's it it was a touching
moment it was shocking at first but I
was like but then it was also built to
be like all right I see what y'all doing
I'm going viral I love that and they
went viral by the way they went viral
foreign